guys we have just arrived in the hakuna
matata island and it's called
zanzibar
how's that you could have given it a
little bit more enthusiasm
how on earth do you get more
enthusiastic
this is my good friend nasir who's also
the most enthusiastic person i know
so much so he's made a career out of it
a super successful career at that a
filmmaker with a following of over 40
million people across platform the
reason we find ourselves in zanzibar is
because nasa lives in dubai and i live
in cape town so it seems like a fair
middle ground for us to announce
something that i've been working on for
the last six months something i couldn't
be more excited about i have along with
the nasa academy developed my own
academy where i'll teach you how to
become a great
filmmaker through a seven hour cohort
learning experience i am super proud of
it i've also linked it in the top line
of the description and we'll talk about
it a bit more later but for now i want
to demonstrate through a visual
experiment what would happen if you took
two filmmakers gave them the exact same
brief in the same location with the same
deadline and then looked at the main
product at the dynamics academy you'll
learn how to find your voice as a
filmmaker and make films that are
completely original and unique to you
and your story to really stand out as a
great
filmmaker nasa and i were challenged to
both make our own one minute film about
zanzibar in one day of shooting and see
if they come out any different this is
that story
okay dude you have your idea like it
starts with the title title for you i
come up with the title first yeah
i did that last it has to be about all
of zagheb that's it hakuna matata from
yo that's not a bad idea either a real
life hakuna matata island the second
thing is people nas means people i must
find as many people as possible
okay you should come because you should
come dude i'd love to
it's gonna work it's gonna work and it's
called
what the hell is this shot we're gonna
go up and over if we hit a tree it's not
bad
so dad
what are you looking for i'm looking for
sounds i'm looking forward to what's
known as diegetic sounds the sounds that
objects make and i'm going to create a
local soundtrack out of those songs
[Music]
got it one sound done like 550 to go
[Music]
okay
the mosque and the church are 10 meters
apart
what are you doing dan trying to get a
mood there's no sound
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when i was a kid i thought hakuna matata
was just in the
[Music]
oh movies nice
that was so good
[Music]
okay so we've just both finished filming
our one minute short film but before i
show them to you i want to tell you
about the real reason i'm here with
naziah in zanzibar which is the darn
maze academy this is an academy where
you have a cohort based learning
experience that's not only a refreshing
take on teaching but also helps you
build a community with filmmakers from
all around the world think live sessions
with experienced trainers a lifetime
access to course videos and an insight
into my creative thought process from
ideation and pitch to production and
edit as a result i've been building the
dhan mates academy which encapsulates my
10 year career as a professional
filmmaker into a seven hour learning
experience called how to become a great
filmmaker i will also be hiring
filmmakers from around the world to work
on global projects with me that are
signed up to the academy the academy
also includes monthly meetups with me
where i give you personalized feedback
on your films plus a huge stock file of
my raw footage access to one terabyte of
filmmaking resources including b-roll
footage sample shot lists sample
treatment decks pre-production
checklists and brand email templates
honestly just hanging out with you and
understanding the shots that you take
i feel like i've just gone through film
school again
no i never did okay
fair enough that's good you did it twice
check it out it's in the link in the
description below anyway
back to zanzibar
when i was a kid i thought hakuna matata
was just in the movie but turns out
there's a real hakuna matata island and
it's called
in swahili hakuna matata means no
worries in this island off the coast of
africa people live near and with each
other the population is friendly
the beaches and the tides are absolutely
beautiful the clothes are so colorful
and the tortoises here the second
biggest in the entire world in zanzibar
where mosques are built right next to
churches where the nature is outstanding
and the culture is too you'll find
yourself saying hakuna matata
that's one minute
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the review
oh
mmm
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
that was an incredible demonstration of
how different each film was and what's
beautiful is that neither is right or
wrong there's an audience for both of
them there are millions of ways to make
a film about one idea it just needs your
uniqueness your voice and in this
academy i'll teach you how to find yours
so click on the link in the top line of
my description and sign up today again
i'm super proud of what we as a team
have put together here and i know that
you will benefit hugely from this other
than that don't forget you're awesome
bru and i'll see you next week
[Music]
you